do you like animals depending on what it
is yes I like animals yeah I love
animals they're better than us being
around petén um if they're fuzzy dream
pet list dog goat yak I mean I'm almost
30 I think anything more is gonna put me
in the crazy the crazy been whatever is
in that cage is a big and loud and it's
moving and I'm a little freaked out by
it you wanna meet a friendly creature
sure I'm ready to meet my buddy
Oh nope sorry that I can't spring me you
not today what is it it's a porcupine oh
whoa oh my god hello here's a leaf oh
you want to eat that leave you don't eat
the leaf I'm giving you it's pretty rude
please but does they have the this
pointy things this is the coolest thing
that's ever happened to me I got it's a
baby
there you go a little baby - boy yeah
this is her little baby Oh Mike okay
okay what's the touching situation here
cuz I feel like it could go bad real
quick
quills go in this direction so you can
touch her kind of with the grain like
that
these are so cool they kind of feel like
hey Oh got me it didn't hurt at all this
is like yeah I thought it was a skunk at
first because of the black and white
it's a 45 I know it's probably very
legal but I would definitely put one
these in my large zoo one day we're all
pals like let's go hang out any of these
seven anyone you're my friend no you
know my scent we'll be friends forever
it's just nature happening on the table
and they're eating leaves it's the
cutest thing I've ever seen